the Super Mario Brothers movie is
sitting theaters like a ray of sunshine
and we're thrown back the biggest Mario
Party the galaxy has ever seen he has 64
things you need to know about this
Surefire Smash and its Odyssey to the
big screen
all right
everyone knows that Disney has made
Millions off of live-action versions of
his animated Classics with the Super
Mario Brothers movie illumination is
trying the same thing in Reverse giving
the animated treatment to an obscure 90s
cult classic but why did the studio
known for family-friendly fair look to
inspiration in such an experimental
movie targeted at adults
Bob Hoskins and John leguizama as
Brothers Mario and Luigi Mario the
original Super Mario Bros is a gritty
Dark Fantasy film like Labyrinth crossed
with the Warriors or The Wizard of Oz by
way of CD New York City
do anything for publicity the movie was
little loved and underseen at the time
many critics questioning how two
plumbers navigating a strange world full
of Koopas and Goombas could be
compelling to well anyone but the 1993
movie didn't come out of nowhere the
high concept film was itself based on an
underground TV series starring Captain
Lou Albano you may not remember it but
this brooklyn-based variety show even
inspired fan art as far away as Japan
the series was a lovingly rendered piece
of educational TV along the lines of
Sesame Street or Mr Rogers Neighborhood
because drugs can kill and if you do
drugs you go to hell before you die the
Super Mario Brothers movie is being
targeted towards kids and families but
plenty of things from the horror tins
original still found a home in the new
version there's gotta be a way out of
here
the only hope is this
that's just a few examples a classic
police chase sequence from the 1990s
movie has been reimagined as a
light-hearted go-kart race and the
hulking Goombas have been reimagined as
teen tiny creatures who look like that
collapse from a single Bop To The Head
kids are already going wild for the
cutesy creatures however not everyone is
jazzed for the redesigned Goombas in
response to the reveal of the animated
version one that the user wrote why
Goombas so small LOL
WTF it's not just the creatures of
Mario's world who have seen major
changes while the Bob Hoskins movie took
place in a Loosely realistic version of
New York the new film takes place on
some far away planet called the Mushroom
Kingdom the trippy design of this world
looks straight out of a video game and
seems to be taking inspiration from
another movie about an animated alien
Sonic the Hedgehog another character has
been changed drastically from the
original is a psychotic villain of the
story king cooper no longer an evil
politician who turns into a dinosaur he
now appears to be some kind of full-time
lizard named Bowser fans are sure to
hate this massive change the most the
name Bowser seems to be a tip of the hat
to current Nintendo of America president
Doug Bowser oh
suppressor of the proletari it guy in
charge hey sucker isn't clear what
Nintendo a company largely known for
interactive video games has to do with
the Super Mario Brothers movie but you
may have played a few of its titles
before some of the company's iconic
titles include the leg end of long call
kaibi and oh wait a second uh huh I
guess this Mario guy is in video games
too including one of our favorite
franchises Grand Theft Auto
some really good man
[Music]
thanks for watching and April Fools and
happy birthday to me check out one of
our real videos right here plus even
more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]